Film Courage: How important is it for audiences
to see themselves in the characters they
see on screen? Chris Gore, Founder/Owner of
FilmThreat/Author/Filmmaker: How important is
it for audiences to see themselves? I think they
should see themselves in whoever the protagonist
is but I think the thing that people confuse
is that that that person should look like you
I there are so many times I've seen movies where
I identified with a character who wasn't my age
wasn't my gender wasn't my ethnicity and
I think we live at a time now where people
are so narcissistic they look at movies like
video games when whereas in a video game you
could actually design for many games
design a character that looks like you
that looks almost exactly like you for certain
video games for movies I think what people are
talking about is representation I think I do
believe that representation is something that
is important it's it's important to have you
know different types of people represented
within a story where possible but if you are only
capable of identifying with a character who looks
mostly like you I would say that you're a
narcissist and I think that you you would benefit
greatly from identifying with characters
who don't look like you and quite frankly
I tend to gravitate towards stories where I mean
look I spend all day with myself I don't want
a story about me i'd like to see a story about
a character that takes me to a different place
that is experiencing different challenges in
life that I may never have faced so that I can
safely experience that story through through them
and they don't have to look like
me I think that there's been an
put on that that there needs to be characters that
look just like you well what are we gonna do go
through every single ethnicity gender sexuality
and remake all the stories with characters
that fit every single checkbox I
think that just gets exhausting
I think it gets exhausting and I really
actually tend to gravitate towards stories
in particular world cinema you know I grew
up watching a lot of asian cinema as a kid
and I loved it it was an opportunity
to explore another culture you know
you're gonna think this is crazy but I saw a
movie called godzilla's revenge when I was a kid
and I godzilla is in the movie
and is a hero to a young boy
and he has these fantasies in his head about
godzilla and befriending godzilla's son
minya and within that story with this little
child which is around the same age as me but
not the same ethnicity he was Japanese and but it
was interesting to see how he he ate you know you
know these different experiences in the culture
were very different and I found that just really
fun I connected it with him because he was my same
age it really mattered very little to me that I
looked like the the kid in that movie so I think
you're missing a huge opportunity to experience
the world differently through someone else's
eyes I think that's the whole and I've said
this before it's the purpose of all fiction comic
books movies video games novels to see the world
through the eyes of someone else and and movies
give us an opportunity to do that and if you're
wholly obsessed with a character's gotta be like
you go play a video game design a character that
looks just like you and go play that video game
but you're missing an opportunity certainly when
it comes to comes to movies is there a healthy
aspect of narcissism in cinema I mean imagine
you go through life never seeing yourself in a
film or never seeing yourself in magazines and
then finally now you're seeing people that look
like you that have gone through the same thing
yeah now here here's here's a caveat to that
I would say that you know it's I think it is
important to have different types of people
represented but help me to identify with
that person with their plight their story their
challenges their struggles you know I think this
it's it's a challenge I would lay out
there to independent filmmakers right
have an audience identify with a character that
where the majority of people will identify with
someone who isn't them tell their story I get
involved in the story and the challenges for that
character I don't necessarily tend to focus so
much on on you know who the person is from their
you know outward traits right I mean one of my
heroes growing up was the character Ripley from
alien that one is brought up quite a bit Sigourney
Weaver is so great I mean even even in the
even in the episodes or the the the sequels in
you know the alien movies that are not that great
she's always great Sigourney
Weaver always seems to deliver
and you know I saw that when I was a kid wasn't
her age wasn't I you know I was not a woman
and you know like I still identified with her
mainly because I thought she was the smartest
person the other thing people
forget about the first alien movie
I mean there's a book about this save the cat
right she went back and saved Jonesy the cat
and I think that that that was one of the
things that and this happens late in the movie
right so obviously she has a relationship with
this cat Jonesy and identified with that because
you know what I have a cat you know at the time
I had a cat I pretty much have always had cats so
or you know it just I think that that's an easy
way to identify what is self-insert a self-insert
in a movie is when someone will literally take
themselves and just make them the hero of the
story and I I find that to be kind of off-putting
we we've seen it happen it happens it's happening
now with more frequency where you see you you
see a move and you're like okay well that's
interesting who that person is and then when
you find out the backgrounds of the creators
it tends to just be almost exactly like them
down to even some physical attributes and I'll
say that many are guilty of this if you look
at the work of works of say David Cronenberg
or even David Lynch Kyle Mclaughlin is pretty
much a self-insert for for David Lynch kind of
wide-eyed about the world and if you compare their
haircuts at the time they pretty much had the same
hair same thing with same same thing with David
Cronenberg right I mean when you know he used
Jeremy Irons in was it dead ringers he I mean it
looks like David Cronenberg let's be honest right
so you see when filmmakers do this sometimes
I think they do it subconsciously but you're
seeing I think it more and more and it can be used
to good effect and you know I mean George Lucas
named the lead character of his Star Wars
saga Luke kind of after himself Luke Lucas
you know that could be argued so self-insert
I think as long as you're aware can work I
think when it's done almost to an exacting
point I don't know that it that it succeeds
every time what if we just own our narcissism and
say okay I like to see myself on screen like that
well I think the very act of thinking that someone
would be interested in a story that you thought up
in your brain is kind of narcissistic to begin
with to think well I have this idea in my head
I'm gonna make a film write a film make a film
produce a film direct to film whatever part of
the process you exist in I'm gonna do that and
then you're gonna give me money to see this story
yeah that I mean look you have to have
sort of a healthy level of narcissism
but I think that needs to be balanced with
self-awareness I think it's absolutely critical
that you have a profound self-awareness to be
able to balance that narcissism and just keep
it so it's it's not the thing that dominates
I mean one thing I would if I could throw some
couple tips out to writers one keep a blazer in
your car wherever you go you never know where
you're gonna be where throwing on a blazer whether
it's a casual one like I have now or whatever you
just throw it even over a t-shirt it immediately
sort of ups your game right some level of
upscale casual the other thing is I never
go anywhere without carrying notebooks
right so I always have a tiny notebook very
tiny that fits in the back of my pocket and
I'll carry this notebook around and I'll jot down
ideas and it's better than yeah I know we want to
use the notes function in your phone no this is
better there's something about sitting there with
a pen and I always carry a pen the space pen the
space pen is in my pocket currently oh great okay
but this goes in my back pocket and then the
problem is I believe leading a creative life where
there are financial concerns you have to balance
two things one is you know obviously being
able to be creative the second thing is being
successful from a business standpoint and that's
why you need a notebook that's a little thicker
probably like this and I hate to tell you this
you're gonna spend your creative time probably
like this and your business time in order to
succeed in the film industry a little more
like this notebook this is like a a moleskin
and I think completely describes my sentiments
for dealing with that aspect of the industry
and where does everybody's narcissism fit into
that so they've got their blazer they've got the
two books the small one for creativity the
large one for business but then we're all
narcissist in one way or another where where
how do we balance that you you balance that
with being humble so that you keep that narcissism
in check but be bold right and and that comes with
asking questions it comes with relating to people
and not by text and not by social media posts
I mean actually talking to people and I and
especially when I meet young filmmakers today they
I just see that they haven't learned all
the lessons and they're maybe out of balance
and the thing I see most often is just relating
to people one-on-one face-to-face so you know
throw on a blazer or something upscale casual
that you feel comfortable in that represents you
and how you feel about yourself and and and go
out there and ask questions and don't be afraid
don't be afraid to say hello don't be afraid to
say hi don't be afraid to say hi if you run into
me I'll probably say hi back and and we may get
no conversations probably because you know if if
you meet me in person you even know who the heck
I am you know we probably are into the same things
movies is a great place to connect with
anybody because who who doesn't like movies
why why are you why are you watching
me why are you watching this channel
yeah I've had some great conversations with total
strangers after movies it's great I know I've said
this before but it's it's movies are a way to have
a conversation about anything anything in life
so be fearless about having those conversations
and keep your narcissism in check I I'll say
just like when it comes to people I have met
in the industry people at the highest levels
I'm talking about major celebrities superstars
are the most humble people I've ever met and then
it's generally the people that are sort of
trying to claw their way to the top that
that you see are kind of having that
that that struggle with their own ego
why do you love movies so much I
feel like I love movies because it's
like it's like a waking dream right it's it's
a it's a dream and an experience where you can
you know enter the mind of a character and
experience the world through their eyes and
it's it's actually safe right whether that
character you know gets horribly injured has
terrible things happen to them or loses
you know loved ones friends family members
you're you're able to experience those things the
kinds of things that everybody experiences in life
in a way that's safe and in a way that imparts
lessons whether you're aware of it at the time
or not there's something in our lizard brain that
responds to storytelling because I think it's
it's it's a way for us to exercise our
own demons or to deal with loss and pain
from our past and that's why I think
storytelling and in particular movies
and in particular movies and seeing a movie in
a theater when it's dark and you're focused and
you're not on your phone you're not distracted
although I will say there is an entire category
of movies that I would say this would be a good
movie to watch while you're folding laundry
and I have watched those movies and I have
folded laundry while I've watched them
but the a film I know I'm really going to care
about I'm going to see in a theater in the dark
experience the world through that character's
eyes and and come out the other end better for it
and it's so universal that feeling that feeling
that's why you know wherever you go in the world
people people love to you know have us have a
story unfold on the big screen I think there's
something primal about that that goes back to
telling stories around the campfire or just a fire
right there's there's something about it that's
just embedded in our heads and that's why you know
the love and passion for film is so universal
worldwide and when did you find that category of
the folding laundry film I think the folding
laundry film came during the pandemic in
terms of watching stuff I probably would not
have watched otherwise when it's just well
we're here there's no movies at the theater
I'm gonna watch this thing and so I think
there is an entire category of movies and a lot
of I would say series television where you can
get a lot of the story that is happening just from
the it's just from hearing it so it's kind of an
a radio play and they say that the original star
trek series if you're not watching it if you're
just listening to it and I can confirm this
because when I was a kid I used to record the
audio of old episodes of star trek and listen to
them and even though I wasn't seeing everything
when I would listen to those cassette tapes
later I still got got the story you know all
of your narrative points your your character
moments you know your drama from the music
there there's a whole world of just like just that
that you can experience just from listening to it
and I would I would recommend just as an exercise
for fun some of the content on streaming services
like netflix you can get not just the captions
on but there's a thing called audio description
and I strongly recommend that you do this
try this out for fun take something you like
if audio description is an option that's
available it's for people who are disabled
may may not be able to see and not only do you
hear the dialogue you hear a description of a
narrator telling you what has is happening
action wise on the screen it's it's in a way
almost like having the screenplay read to you
it's it's I mean it obviously has a function
a useful function for people who are unable
to see but it also as as a way of learning
you know you you can you can listen to these
heck you can listen to them while you're driving
and you get the entire story the audio descriptive
version there's even you can look this up
online there's there are people who list some of
the best audio descriptive versions of content
so I find it really useful I think it's
interesting but the folding laundry yes I
think we've all had that experience where
you're like this thing that I'm about to
watch doesn't deserve all of my attention
for me it's generally romantic comedies I
romantic comedies as much as I am sometimes forced
to watch them I feel like that's that's something
I can multitask and still enjoy okay so suppose
tonight is laundry night so after this interview
I'm gonna you know go down to the
laundromat and then I'm gonna come back
and start folding and organizing can you recommend
two movies for me oh sure I marry me with jennifer
lopez which I saw recently that's a totally a full
laundry movie and I would say death on the nile
for recent films okay they may not be recent when
you're watching this I have no idea when you're
watching this when are you watching this I don't
know all right great I want to do laundry right
now check them out but we all know we have those
right everyone where you're just like this is like
my full attention is going on this Christopher
Nolan movie or whatever it is we're seeing like
I you know I'm gonna turn off the lights and I
have my little I have like this sort of led like
blue light that goes around my television kind
of kind of makes a movie theater experience in 4k
whatever but then there's other things where
you're like now I'm just going to have this on
in the background or for me it's even a movie I've
seen so many times I can quote the entire film
or what's great is when you think you're going
to watch a film like that and you're actually
surprised like I was watching old episodes do
you remember VR5 no I don't remember oh okay
so it had Lori Singer and it was about her she had
this gift of being able to go into virtual reality
and she was the only one that had this ability
and so she was being like wanted by big tech
at that time which was in the mid 90s and it
the storytelling was excellent you know it's
got cool old graphics and modems but I thought oh
this is the perfect thing to put on and actually
I couldn't do anything else right right like some
of those you put on thinking like ah whatever I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna I'm gonna organize my
receipts right okay that's something here to do
you put something on and then you do get caught
up I mean that's that's a pleasant surprise but
but I kind of plan my viewing that way because
I tend to watch at least a movie a day if not
more it's just part of what I do what does an
American film mean today I really think that
there is no American cinema today the last great
era of American cinema was in the 70s and probably
the 80s as well but I think that the American
identity is so fractured because of current day
politics that there's almost no such thing
as a movie that everybody can get behind
I think the most recent example of one was the
latest spider-man movie spider-man no way home
which was a an incredibly fun like spider-man not
just a spider-man movie it's a spider-man movie
that was built up over 20 years of spider-man
movie fandom starting with toby mcguire
andrew garfield you know and and building up to
this where now that all the spider-men are are
united that was like hey we can all get behind
this you know it's a completely fun superhero
movie ride we can all get behind it is that an
American film I don't know I would argue that the
superhero genre is something that's very American
made but I really feel we've lost our identity
as a country because it's so fractured
into multiple different americas
and I'll give you an example this is
a weird thing I did I did a panel at a
convention called politicon and I pitched a
panel called trump the movie and I had a friend
of mine who was a screenwriter I had a friend of
mine who worked in film development and I asked
like you know almost every president post their
presidency has a movie made about them right not
a documentary a dramatic movie that you know sort
of goes through the highlights the low lights and
you know and and I wondered if if a trump movie
would ever be made how would you market that movie
and I got it was a very interesting discussion
because we got into this whole thing of like okay
you make the movie whatever the movie is what
kind of movie would it be would it be more
comedic would it be sort of farcical you know like
maybe maybe like from the mind of adam mckay or
something like that you know like like what would
it be one but then here becomes the challenge of
marketing that movie which comes back
to the question of American cinema
okay you've made a movie about the trump
presidency who is it for and how do you market it
do you do a marketing campaign that is for the red
states that makes trump look like a hero do you
do another campaign another marketing campaign
from the same movie that talks about how he's
a horrible human being and this one these are the
trailers you would run in the blue states I think
it would be really interesting to see and which
is why I think a movie like that will not be made
I don't think that there'll be a dramatic telling
of his story of of the trump presidency it's just
not going to happen and I think it has to do
with our fractured America that's why we have no
really cohesive American cinema I think that there
are outside interests and the concerns of our
corporate factory filmmaking are that
this movie needs to play globally
so it that again and I've talked about this
many times the check boxes that need to go
you know in order for something to play to the
world means that you've you've kind of distilled
it and and it's not really a holy American
american movie and the only way you would notice
this is if you watched a lot of foreign foreign
films or or what they call now world cinema so
I would say to you I say as an exercise
for yourself watch a Canadian movie
watch a Canadian is very Canadian and you know
the a lot of countries actually subsidize their
filmmakers and and the arts and in particular
is the Canadian film board that you pitch a
movie to the Canadian film board has to have
a certain percentage of Canadian talent in it
large percentage it has to have Canadian
themes and made for people in Canada
and there are a lot of things you
know if you're watching this you're
American you're not going to get
the jokes I grew up in Michigan
just outside of of Canada and and so I experience
the CBC I watch Canadian children's programming
I watch Canadian movies I watch Canadian hockey
I became a hockey fan from watching the cbc but
it's really interesting to see how distinct
the American identity is to the Canadian
Canadian culture so do yourself a favor and watch
see films from other countries and you'll notice
how important it is for those countries to to lay
out their identity and their culture in particular
french cinema does that as well so i'd say broaden
your horizons broaden your media diet and you'll
just notice that most of the movies that are
made in America now are not for America they're
for the globe they just are and so I think what's
happened is it's eroded our identity as Americans
or something we could get behind because like
I said you're going to make a movie about trump
you're going to have two marketing campaigns for
that movie no matter what that movie ends up being
well let's suppose we just take the name trump
out of it we could use any president really in
the last let's say 20 years we could use any media
figures in the last few years if we were to have a
trailer that was specific to their audience
wouldn't it be almost considered propaganda
well I would say that at least when it comes to
to documentaries it's almost all propaganda now
I mean I would say to documentary filmmakers it's
just like I I see a lot of docs small indie docs
that come to Film Threat for us to look at
and it's almost all solidly on one side of
the equation or the other I've seen you know
pro-trump documentaries I've seen anti-trump
documentaries I would say that the only one that
was truly unbiased was made by a british filmmaker
called the accidental president oh yes I
heard of that yeah and I strongly recommend
the accidental president it's it's just one
because it's made by a brit is just like look
got no skin in the game you know let's let's
look at trump as a person and and what he did
and it's it's it's really fascinating because I
think it's an it's an unbiased look at that at
his run for the presidency but really most
political documentaries I see now they're
either I can already tell it's like oh team red
team blue where where where what happened to
being unbiased what happened to being a journalist
and seeking out truth no matter where it leads you
know that used to be the way things were not sure
what happened to that you know and I've often said
film thread my media outlet FilmThreat[dot]com
where we review independent films we're
politically agnostic we have people on all sides
you know on all different diversities of thought
I think is my more what takes priority with me and
I do enjoy reading someone whose opinion doesn't
completely line up with mine it's an opportunity
to to learn something but I but I really see a
fracture in in the world of doc filmmaking where
most of what's being produced is purely propaganda
you know there was a a and and to be clear
my politics are very middle of the road
you know sure I can sit here and talk to you all
day about Star Wars and Star Wars is actually a
good place I'm sure we'll get to some Star
Wars talk Star Wars a good place because
it's a thing that most people have seen 99.9 of
people have seen it so it's a great entry point
to talk about lots of issues that particular
movie or film series and all that it begat
but but boy we we've really gotten to
a place now where I just have concerns
about we've lost the ability to objectively
look at facts and I think that's lazy here's why
it bothers me it's lazy because just as someone
who's politically been in the middle which means I
generally despise both sides you know I think
that let's come up with solutions to problems
and if you're focused on the solution really
well it shouldn't matter necessarily your the
politics or what you may be compromised by when
it comes to your donors but I but now I feel
that if you are on one side of the other I feel
that that in my opinion is kind of lazy because
what what it says is the thinking is done for
you which is why I think there are many ways
to look at an issue so I would just like to
see documentary filmmaker filmmaking become
less less biased I think I think that
would be a great service to all of us
is writing weaker today than it used to be I
would say absolutely writing is weaker today
and and I I've looked at this and and I think
the disappointment I have about it is that one
we live in a time where media is so accessible
in two clicks you can see anything including
movies that just opened in theaters right like
whether it's available on a streaming service or
whether there are other means so much content and
I despise that word but I'll use it so much is
available to us that what I fear is the current
generation of writers are not influenced by
life they're not influenced by great novels that
they've read they're not influenced by classic
films they're not influenced by travel where
they've traveled the world they're not influenced
by loves that they've had great loves they've had
or loves they've lost they're not influenced by
parenting experiences that they might have
had or experiences with family or experiences
real world real life experiences my concern is
that most movies being written today movies and
television are written by a generation that
is influenced by other movies so there's this
snake eating its tail of writers influenced
by other things they've seen rather than life
experiences when you look at the very first Star
Wars movie George Lucas I know I bring it up a lot
but Star Wars was influenced by many
things you know serials from the 1930s
from things like flash gordon and buck rogers I
mean George Lucas famously just wanted to make
flash gordon but had trouble with getting the
rights it was influenced by Marvel comics it was
influenced by a tragic event where he
almost died in a car accident and was
in the hospital for a long period of time and
that near-death experience changed george lucas
much much of his influence
was from also his father
in his life who was a successful
business person who he looked up to
a lot of his experience was growing up in Modesto
people you know the obsession over car culture
and hot rods when you see that in the character
of Han Solo you know it's kind of a guy who's
into hot rods the millennium falcon is a hot
rod but so much of the influences that George
had both from life and so much classic literature
and storytelling were kind of thrown in a blender
and now you've got every Star Wars movie is
just influenced by the last Star Wars movie
or the last Star Wars tv show or what they
call this horrible term member berries which
is we're going to sort of throw out these member
berries remember that remember that character
remember this character remember that and what it
does is it takes it completely takes the mystery
half of the fun of some of these characters from
the star the world of Star Wars is the fact that
we didn't know anything about them that we could
use our imagination so what's happening is the
what you're doing in it is you've got this
generation of writers that are weaker because
they're just influenced by the previous work
right and then secondarily you're taking
you're you're dumbing down the
audience and making them lazier because
they're they're not able to even make up something
in their head about a character that was once
mysterious and had two or three minutes of total
screen time in a film series Boba Fett now you've
expanded on him to the point where okay we get it
we know everything about this character right like
and and I find that disconcerting you know I don't
know I I think that there's something to be said
from work that comes from older writers who have
had some life experience I can always spot just
because I've had kids and raised kids who are now
off on their own and pay their own bills which is
awesome but having been through that experience I
can always see how false a parenting relationship
is when I see whether it's a filmmaker writer
director who has never had children in their lives
and I see and there's like oh a dad would never do
that or no way would a mother act that way towards
a child I just I kind of see that and I think it
just there's a falseness that just comes from my
personal experience that now does it completely
ruin the movie not necessarily not necessarily
but I think that writers would benefit from
having the time to experience much of life first
and then bringing that to their writing not in the
way of like necessarily a self-insert but at least
being able to what is it like to lose a loved one
and happen you know have it happen right
in front of you you know what I mean that
that kind of experience if you've ever been in the
room where someone close to you has passed away
very difficult experience to go through and
part of the therapy dealing with that is
through creativity and writing so I do think
that our current generation of writers is
is weak because they haven't taken
the time to have those experiences
sure there's the age thing do you think
the internet plays a lot into that because
let's say gen xers we didn't have access to
that and maybe baby boomers and beyond that
we couldn't just easily go on rotten
tomatoes or imdb and look something up
right and in some ways that's wonderful but in
some ways maybe it's a disservice to creativity
so yeah I think access to too much information
can can hamper creativity you know when you're
bombarded by too much I think I think that that
can hurt I think going on a writing sabbatical is
good with no computer you know again bring your
notebook they're portable they go anywhere they
never run out of power although your pen might
run out of ink but you know yeah I do think that
life experience is incredibly important and
when you look at the stories of how some
great works were written the stories behind
those whether it's a film or a novel or whatnot
there's always more to the story there's
always more to the story of the primary
creative person involved what about the type of
life and the type of experiences this person has
had because you know there could be some people
that they maybe had more of a sheltered existence
so they're only going to have a certain
frame of reference for writing a story
whereas I've known some people that they've gone
to europe didn't tell their family had just the
clothes on their back and learned to survive there
for a month somehow and came back unscathed but
that would that's a different life experience than
your parents driving you to college and getting
you set up in your dorm room well I think I
think the reason that we live in such a bizarrely
divided time where people are fighting over in
my opinion some of the stupidest arguments I've
ever heard and I think part of it is that we need
struggle and we need adversity because I believe
that struggle when it comes to us as a human
self is and the way of overcoming a struggle
is this is gonna sound strange is puzzle solving
it's overcoming that is you know in a video game
it's leveling up right but I think part of the
struggle is okay here you know you're you're not
making ends meet with your bills you're gonna
keep having that problem until you do something
different you know your relationship's
not working out well it's probably not
the people that you're dating it might be you and
the choices that you're making solve that problem
and I feel like we live in a time where people
are kind of manufacturing problems to experience
adversity that they're really not able
to experience in their real lives which
explains to so much of the nonsense that you see
online with people battling each other each other
over things that are pointless I try to not get
involved in those kinds of discussions I find them
a waste of time and you know time is limited I
want to focus on the things that matter right and
choose to use my time in a way that's wise where
I end up with a result I can look back and go okay
I sacrifice not arguing with people on twitter
six hours a day but look what I was able to do
or rather than writing thousand 500 word thousand
word facebook posts arguing how right I am about
a thing I wrote a thousand words a day and
in two months I had enough for a book enough
material for a book which is technically what you
would have if you wrote a thousand words a day
for two months you'd have enough material for a
book so I think that as humans you know we we seek
out as a way to kind of level up or
or improve our situation we need that
because and this is why this is going to sound
like even more of a weird rabbit hole you can
go down and research this even is puzzles are
so popular puzzles gaming video gaming you know
puzzle solving checkers chess I mean look at
the history of gaming through humanity right
there's a reason video games are more popular than
movies video games make more money than movies
and the fun of a video game is solving a problem
and I think we need that we need that our human
we need to puzzle solve solve issues we
need we need adversity to fight against to
level up I think it's it's your self-awareness
you know plays a lot into are you going to keep
going down that road and making that same mistake
and spending all that time on social media arguing
with people you've never met or maybe like
divert that energy into something more useful
so that would be my advice there but go
down the rabbit hole of puzzles through
human history and you'll find that it's something
that that humans have kind of always had around
in addition I would I would research and look
into how children learn do children learn through
memorization they can yeah memorization
is a great technique for kids to learn
more effective is turning things into games or
puzzles kids love it and they gravitate towards
it what if we're not designed to be totally
harmonious and what if groups need a scapegoat
because it makes them closer so the group can
bond if they have an enemy yeah that's a scary
thought that you just expressed and I and I
and I see that when it comes to our current
climate I think that that's something as a human
species that we need to overcome I think we have
to overcome the the inclination to do that to
vilify someone as a way to feel superior as a
way to other them and vilify whatever it happens
to be about we must learn to resist that urge
to do that and to have some empathy for someone
who may not think the way that you do who
who who may live a life that you don't 100
percent approve of now if that person isn't
doing anything that hurts anybody else I
don't know why that that would bother you
for some people it does and I think that that
we have not as a species reached that point yet
I like to think that in the Gene Roddenberry
future that he envisioned for star trek in
the original series and and next generation they
talk about having overcome those types of things
and a more elevated existence were certain
types of things well as a human race we got
over that right well we certainly haven't in
our present day and I hope that we learn too
why do popular franchises fail I feel that popular
franchises tend to fail because corporations are
incapable of making them under the current factory
filmmaking conditions one popular franchises are
created generally by a singular person who was not
paid by a company to think that up that it was an
idea that came not necessarily fully formed
but percolated for years from that person's
experiences whether it's a Gene Roddenberry with
star trek whether it's a George Lucas with Star
Wars whether it's a J. R. R. Tolkien with the Lord
of the Rings series a franchise comes birthed from
a person not because a company hired them to
think up a new franchise it came out of someone
because it was a creative thing that they needed
to express and big companies which are required
to fully fund a huge property or
franchise the conditions under which
content is made at those corporations is
not conducive to a singular creative voice
it's art by committee there are
other concerns budget is a concern
is it going to have a happy meal I mean Tim
Burton famously got in trouble after the
sequel to his 1989 Batman film starring Michael
Keaton the second movie Batman returns was
much darker in tone and more to Tim Burton's
creative liking and it infuriated McDonald's
because here was a movie that was kind of
frightening to young children they even McDonald's
even issued an apology there are videos on YouTube
you can look up about this McDonald's actually
issued an apology when they released a series of
penguin catwoman and Batman toys because the movie
didn't really fit the young demographic
that would have bought say a happy meal
so you've got your your your budget concerns
your are we going to be able to make toys are we
going to be able to you know put the cast in that
we want like in addition to concerns about well
this movie costs a lot is it
going to play in other countries
is it going to play to a worldwide audience
because we're spending 400 million dollars
on this thing once you have all of these concerns
on the shoulders of a creator it's very difficult
it's very difficult to come out the other end
with something that still has that vibrancy
of a single creative vision now some filmmakers
have learned to work within that system very well
I would say that Christopher Nolan is one of the
filmmakers that has had more success than failure
in in that working within that system although
they've been you know I don't know if there was a
happy meal necessarily for the dark knight Batman
movie I don't remember actually I should know that
but his other films as well in addition someone
like a Denis Villeneuv with Dune he was able to
balance the studio concerns and have a
vision that was his vision of the novel
Frank Herbert's original novel for Dune so it can
be done but I do think that it requires a singular
creative visionary that has the full support of
the studio when they say look when Chris Nolan
says we're not going to do inception toys maybe
listen to Chris Nolan that like hey this movie
I don't think that toys are necessarily gonna work
with this right so but when I think once you have
you know signed over the rights to whatever it
is star trek Star Wars a Lord of the Rings and
handed it over to a group of people who never
created it to begin with then what you've got
is you've got that new creative team now
saying I'm going to do my version of this
when it's something that maybe George Lucas
would never have allowed to have happened
or a Gene Roddenberry would have said that
doesn't fit the universe where Tolkein
would have said no this is not what would have
happened in this universe they're not there to
be the checks and balances so when you've lost
that primary creative voice and it just becomes
a piece of ip you know when it's looked on as
intellectual property and then you've even got
in that mix the concerns of stockholders now
for the company like well you know we're just
going to do this because it will appease
the stockholders you have so many concerns
it's a miracle that almost anything worth
watching comes out of a studio these days
so I think that's where they go wrong is you've
lost the original person who is the shepherd for
the franchise whether they're actually directly
doing the writing or not right so you've
when you've lost that shepherd and it goes to
a corporation I don't think a corporation is
the best fit for the most positive result it can
happen and it does happen there are glimpses but
for the most part I think the era that era
is gone I don't think we'll ever see like
a George Lucas or Gene Roddenberry or someone
like that ever again the hoops that you have
to jump through the concerns that you have to
balance stockholders toys budget this you know
it's it's amazing I think that's a skill unto
itself now I would love to hear and I've had
very frank and honest discussions with friends
of mine in the indie film world who all say
you know it's almost like a lot of these movies
the story behind the scenes of making the movie
turns out better that's a more interesting story
than the movie because the fact that okay we got
the financing but the girlfriend of the main
investor who's putting in 10 million dollars
she needs to be the lead and she's not that great
and so you're juggling I can even I can almost
tell when I see a small indie mover I'm like oh
these are the compromises that person had to make
because these are the weakest parts of the movie
and the filmmaker is just fingers crossed hoping
you don't notice so it's almost as if I think
a lot of filmmakers would benefit from you know
taking some courses in therapy in diplomacy and
in finance in addition to being decent at making
films in order to be able to set those concerns
aside and and make something creatively fulfilling
and worthwhile with that singular vision but I see
franchises you know going off the rails and I'm
like it's just too many cooks it's it's corporate
content too many cooks made by you know committee
and you you can just see it you know this recent
teaser for the Lord of the Rings the rings of
power just came out and there's a 56 second
trailer for it and I'm looking at it and to me
it looks like a powerpoint presentation
that was shown to Amazon to sell the series
I don't know what connection it has to Lord of
the Rings to me it looks like dollar store game of
thrones I it doesn't have the feeling of the Lord
of the Rings it's a miracle that Peter Jackson
was able to make Lord of the Rings with
with his own creative vision but being
incredibly respectful of the source material and
that's a thing that I think is not spoken about
enough the respect for the source material and
I know that Peter Jackson he's even spoken about
this you can look up interviews with Peter Jackson
he said you know I have my own personal ideas but
these aren't my ideas this is tolkien's story I'm
going to tell his story and this will be you know
his own vision of that and I think that I actually
think that part of the reason that peter jackson's
original three Lord of the Rings trilogy turned
out so well was because he made it in new zealand
far away from the distractions of
that could have consumed him from
you know the corporate overlords in in in
Hollywood so so being off making those movies
away from that distraction in in new
zealand I think actually helped quite a bit
we have this quote here we actually have two
quotes I don't know if you want to turn around
I know we said you weren't allowed to look
at it at first and now we have the big reveal
and I'm assuming you probably know these
quotes maybe you don't but if you want to
read them for our audience I would like to yes
okay great we made a promise to ourselves at the
beginning of the process that we weren't going
to put any of our own politics our own messages
or our own themes into these movies in a way we
were trying to make these films for him the author
not for ourselves well that's Peter Jackson
and he's talking about J.R.R. Tolkien
and this was his idea when they began to work on
the Lord of the Rings trilogy and arguably the
Lord of the Rings trilogy of movies is the most
successful one of the most successful trilogies in
all of movie history and I say this for a couple
reasons one we don't talk about it very often
and I mean that in a good way meaning we're
not trying to wrestle with its failure we're
not saying well the third movie didn't land you
could say that for christopher nolan's dark knight
trilogy you could say that you could even
say that for the original trilogy for some
the the Return of the Jedi did not completely
work so many trilogies or film franchises
you know this is I think where the term stick the
landing came from and you know Peter Jackson was
able to do that and I think it was because he
stuck with this philosophy from the beginning
he trusted in the story he trusted in the source
material he had the utmost respect for it and yes
he made changes to make it to make it translatable
to the screen in a way that would appeal to people
who are not fans of the source material of the
original books of which I am one I've never read
the books not to say that I wouldn't be a fan if I
would read them but sword and sandal wizardry that
kind of it's not my personal favorite thing I'm
i'm more of a science fiction buff when it comes
to genre material that I like so the fact that I'm
a fan of the Lord of the Rings films because of
how successfully it was pulled off I think that's
saying something and I think it comes from the
it really comes from that first trailer the
first trailer for the first Lord of the Rings
film when you go back and watch the preceding
trailers really got you engaged in frodo's story
and gave you a glimpse into what this journey
would be like and what the stakes were and also
the music music's amazing but if you
watch that the original trailers for
the original the very first Lord of the
Rings film the fellowship of the ring um
it's I mean it gives me chills just even thinking
about it conversely with the Amazon series
which is being made for money which you could
argue all movies are you know all movies are made
for money but I think when when also it's coming
from a a need to creatively express something I
think that that's much more powerful and and when
you compare the original trailer for the first
Lord of the Rings movie with this current upcoming
Lord of the Rings series the rings of power it
just seems like no comparison to me that trailer
looks like dollar store game of thrones it looks
fairly generic you know there are other criticisms
about the you know the look of it not being you
know faithful to the source material I can't
speak to that because I've never read those books
I just love a great story I it's not present yes
it's a teaser trailer so let's cut it some slack
I am hoping that even though this quote is from
Peter Jackson that the makers of the new Lord of
the Rings series would keep some philosophy
like that in mind in fact that's actually a
very good guide for any person who is embarking
on the journey of making a franchise project
for which they did not create that franchise
that's a good that's a good mission statement
we have a second quote no let's read the sentence
let's let's okay it felt only natural to us
that an adaptation of the author's work would
reflect what the world actually looks like
I believe I don't know who
said that but I believe that
is from the makers of the new Lord of the Rings
the rings of power and my concern about that is
that it's they're already giving themselves an
out to stray from the original source material
Tolkein made a world that looked like well the
world he created I don't understand why you would
stray from that I can get you know what
their corporate reasons are but I think more
a more compelling reason would be
the creative reasons for that it
it to me that statement that that quote is
an excuse to to turn it into something that
I mean what are they going to do the concerns
of what are they new they're going to put
hip-hop music in there because hip-hop is very
popular is that what they're going to be doing
at the at the you know it's whenever they do that
I mean I've noticed it in previous franchise well
this is especially in particular music is the
thing like well this is the popular music now so
let's have somebody sing a rap song in a star trek
movie okay those things always they never work
and what it does is it dates it and what I what
I what I think that where it tends to work better
is sort of a timelessness to the storytelling
yeah so that that second quote is is really
troubling to me it's it's corporate speak for
we're gonna do whatever the hell we want and
damn your allegiance or love of this franchise
because we're just gonna do what we think is right
and I don't agree with that speaking of Tolkein
and like old books I was watching a quick trailer
on a woman who runs an old bookstore and and about
collectibles and she said basically when we get
these old books we need to take very good care
of them and we need to know we're just kind of
keeping them for future generations because when
we pass on someone else will be getting this book
and we're sort of like keepers of the book do you
feel like in some sense it's the same thing with
the storytelling like we're really just here for
future generations making sure that it's preserved
well I love that sentiment and I hope it holds
but I think we're living at a time now where
everything creative is being
undone and remade and not with
the interests of preserving the original author's
intention whatever era that person came from
so I love that because I am someone who still goes
to used bookstores so I I love that sentiment I
have concerns that that the same respect is not
being paid by the corporations that purchase
these franchises for the purposes of
updating them and you know adding things that
that just don't work that just they just stand
out and they just like it's like oh they're doing
an update well that's over I mean you see it in
desperation there are certain sort of tropes of
things that would happen I mean they call it in
television they call it jumping the shark right
in the happy days television show when
they did like this two-parter where fonzie
is something you would never see fonzies he's
water skiing and you see a shark and he literally
jumps over this incline over the shark he
jumps the shark this is now happening in in
movies right it happens a lot in you always knew a
franchise was over when they would bring in a cute
character in older television shows they bring in
some cute younger character because some of the
child actors had already aged up it's the cousin
oliver syndrome look that up brady bunch it's a
reference I'm dating myself but like and and they
even made a joke about it in the simpsons with
itchy and scratchy they brought in a character
called pucci which was a skateboard riding
you know backwards baseball cap animal character
that wrapped and Poochie was meant to appeal to
the kids and that is a very simplified version
of exactly what we're discussing right now it's
when you're updating it to a modern audience
you're you're you run the risk of you know one
creatively it's not gonna it's not gonna work and
secondly you are going to alienate the audience
that has lived with these stories for decades
and probably read it when they were younger
and have visions in their mind that are better
than a movie that you could ever make so ah
that that quote is very troubling to me the latter
one yes that last quote is very troubling to me
without checking your phone can you name all of
the Christmas films you can think of oh wow well
there's a lot there's so many that I love it's
a wonderful life a Christmas story bad santa god
they're I mean the I don't know if you consider
the grinch still Christmas it's not a Christmas
movie per se but I always associate that with
Christmas along with the peanuts Christmas special
I mean oh god there's a bunch those are just
like off the top of my head my personal favorites
the ones that I make sure to watch every year
and then there's ones that people would argue
aren't necessarily Christmas movies like Die Hard
but I would put that in that category just
because I love the whole I think it's become
an ugly Christmas sweater that says ho ho ho now
I have a gun I've seen people wear that costume
so you would consider Die Hard a Christmas movie
for me it is for me Die Hard is a Christmas movie
yeah what needs to happen in a Christmas film does
Christmas need to be saved yeah it's I wonder if
you could even make an earnest Christmas movie
now that isn't relegated to the Hallmark Channel
and by that I mean a wide release Christmas movie
that that goes to theaters that would appeal to
people who don't care about Christmas it's just
a heart-warming movie that takes place over the
holidays I think that the thing that needs to
to happen in a Christmas movie one it's gotta
take place during Christmas which Batman returns
by Tim Burton does it takes place during Christmas
it also somehow the message of Christmas has to be
in there woven in some way a realization a love of
fellow your fellow man and and I think that has to
be a big part of it and lessons have to be learned
right I think that's part of Christmas is this for
me there's a feeling that exists around Christmas
that is palpable and it usually starts around
you know Christmas eve night that you could just
feel and Christmas is the next day and it's
sort of a it's it's sort of a reconfirmation
of your relationships of people
close to you and your family
or your significant other and and a way to reach
out to family and friends and you know say hey I
care about you so that has to be a big a big
part of it even if it's woven in in the most
simple way yes I know that it's a wonderful
life is it's dated but I feel like what's sad
to me is that certain people would think that
the message of it's a wonderful life is dated
that is where I have concerns because
I feel that and in particular this
comes with acts of heroism whether it is in an
actual superhero movie or acts of self-sacrifice
or acts of kindness towards a fellow human for
no reason whatsoever whatsoever other than to
do that and I feel like that as a value
has been lost and I notice it in modern
films and television I feel like that
kindness towards your fellow person human
American you know neighbor it's not as present as
it used to be unfortunately although I will say
if you spent some time on social media and you
get up and walk outside your house and normally
that that feeling isn't present but but Christmas
is is first of all I love those Christmas movies
you know but the peanuts Christmas special would
never be made today in specifically because of the
quotes from the bible and there was
even controversy controversy at the time
about like is this going to be a religious
special and it was and now it's it's something
that has survived till today but I think
it'd be incredibly difficult outside of a
small release religious you know show
film showing at churches and whatnot
or something for the hallmark Hallmark Channel
you wouldn't see those kinds of religious ideals
even if it was simply the ideas without the bible
verses I don't think you would see that and it's
you know it's again it's another fracturing of
our audience right like there's a huge audience
that would love to see a movie about
Christmas even if it's only peripherally
about Christmas right but yeah yeah I think it is
is those values those rituals are they're eroding
and they're not as popular on a mass scale as they
used to be I I'm just saying what I have observed
but try to get a Christmas special with religious
themes that doesn't on a mainstream level it'll
never happen enough something made by a major
corporation is not going to do it it's going to be
relocated to a you know what they call
a vertical which is a small audience
so there you are when would you
typically play a Christmas movie
well Christmas is my second favorite holiday
honestly my first my favorite holiday is
halloween the decorations go up in late september
it's a month-long celebration it's horror movies
for the entire month and so I love halloween
you know Christmas I sort of like once I've
once I'm into the turkey around thanksgiving
then the Christmas movies go into rotation
you know and then it's like the the
ones like which actually still has
some heartfelt messages bad santa you would
not think this and you will never look at a
pickle the same way but bad santa kinda is also
one of my one of my Christmas holiday favorites
if you were to write a Christmas film would
you be the protagonist would you see yourself
in the protagonist well if I wrote a Christmas
movie I would I would not be the protagonist
of that movie I would but i'd like to see if
Hollywood could make a you know a new a new
Christmas movie you know to me one of my all-time
favorites is a Christmas story now could you make
that movie today could you make a movie or a kid
little ralphie just wants a gun for Christmas
you know today's climate it's a little
different you know I would love to see
and I've heard rumors that peter billingsley
is going to do an update of a Christmas story
i'd love to see a sequel to that movie with
his character all grown up you know maybe he
wants a different type of gun for Christmas who
knows but you know that movie is not just about
Christmas it's also a reflection of this of that
this bygone era and I just wonder if Hollywood
is capable of making a movie about Christmas
I feel and this is not so much a reflection of
the industry I think audiences would want
it I think that there's so much cynicism
in the entertainment world and Christmas is
about loving your fellow loving your neighbor
and and unity that I wonder if Hollywood
is even capable of making that type of
film I really wonder that so look do I want to
see the sequel to a Christmas story starring
peter billingsley as a grown-up version of himself
maybe it's set in the 60s I would love to see that
is that gonna happen I don't know is it
gonna happen to a satisfying degree we'll see
maybe he wants a glue gun maybe he's a
crafter I yeah well we'll see but you know
I don't need several glue guns oh good okay so
so someone who makes props and sets and things
but not everybody celebrates Christmas that's true
so so it does alienate many people right different
you know what and in whatever it might just be
non-religious and maybe they don't believe in
consumerism and things like that there could
be a whole anti-corporate angle to it yeah I
mean black friday yeah I mean there have been yeah
there have been movies that have explored the over
commercialization of Christmas that's fine I think
that's part of it I think that's a valid critique
of the holiday and having said that I love the
decorations I love the excuse to get together with
friends and family I love the idea of we're
going to take stock in inventory of the last
year and commit to being say a better person in
the new year maybe there have been lessons learned
and it's that that holiday period where we can
kind of take a step back and assess you know
what have you what have we accomplished what are
we capable of doing how can we do better and and
how can we contribute to a better world
I think that that that idea that message
defies the holiday forget the holiday forget the
commercialization that idea of self-reflection
that I think is just important for anybody
you know no matter whether you like celebrate
the holiday or like it or hate it it doesn't
matter that idea is something I think that we
need to do on an annual basis when you think about
villains what are the characters who come to mind
well I would say the greatest villain
in movie history is Darth Vader
that that would be a great villain that
comes to mind Hans Gruber in Die Hard
I think is is also an incredible villain I
mean here's what's interesting the villains
tend to always be more interesting
than the the protagonist than the hero
why I I think the reason that villains are
much more interesting and much more popular
than the heroes is and I'm sorry to say this I
think they're relatable because they speak to a
darker version of ourselves that exists in all
of us that we resist and the villain is caught
up in a you know in at least not necessarily
the villain but but as an audience member we're
caught up in the like oh well you know i'd
never do that but I guess Darth Vader would
do this thing that I would never do right
and it's it's always a a battle internally
over morality and I think what makes villains
interesting especially really well-crafted
villains is that they don't
think what they're doing is wrong
from their perspective from the villain's point
of view they're right I mean there's a reason that
you know there is the term Thanos was right right
like Thanos's mission was to set the galaxy right
and wipe out half of all life in the
galaxy so that other life could thrive
there's a lot of logic that doesn't work quite
work in the Marvel avengers series you know that
that Thanos ended up being the the main villain
of but people kind of look at that and say well
he has a point you know he has a point about
you know wasting resources of you know so
that's where that term Thanos was right came from
and he is you know at least in the movie infinity
war he's such a big part of that film it really is
his journey through parts of the Marvel universe
right experiencing all of these heroes that
you know we've come to see through their own
individual movies and in infinity war you're
you're on Thanos's journey he's the lead character
of infinity war he's the one that is influencing
all of the events and what's interesting is when
you look at the screen time for villains this is
what this is what's amazing is you can see a movie
that has a great movie villain like a Star Wars
whether it's you know the original series
or Anakin Skywalker and in the prequels and
what's interesting is how much impact a great
movie villain will have with so little screen time
very little screen time but the villain influences
all of the other characters in the movie because
the protagonist is constantly having to react
to some something that the main villain is
responsible for always they're the one that's
like even though they may not be present on screen
the villain the main villain in a story is always
the person that is influencing events so and Darth
Vader to me is the culmination of probably some
of the best aspects of of villains from all types
you know whether it be from you know movie serials
or comic books it's fairly easy to argue that
Darth Vader was very influenced by Dr. Doom from
the Fantastic Four comic books created by Stan Lee
the look of Darth Vader kind of based on that
also based on a little bit of a samurai in there
in terms of the helmet and and other
aspects of Darth Vader's character and
the fact that it took you know you know David
Prowses an actor and then James Earl Jones as
a voice actor to kind of create this and also the
physical look you know the costume designers and
and whatnot and and Ralph Bakshi to kind of
design the character or versions of the character
to what it became on screen so so much went
into the creation of Darth Vader as a villain
and that Darth Vader has a tragic backstory
that only a piece of it becomes revealed
in the second movie in which Darth
Vader appeared the empire strikes back
you know villains have layers heroes are
pretty much like I want to do the good
thing I'm going to resist doing the bad thing
okay villains there's much more tragedy pain
trauma and I think that that actually makes them
more relatable not in the sense that we would want
to act out and or emulate any of the things that
a villain on screen would do in particular say
villains from quentin tarantino movies right they
were the you know main antagonists of those of
those of quentin tarantino's films but like it's a
way to kind of like exercise your own demons right
like and that's why I think that movie villains
are so popular and that's why I think that
I don't even think I need to look at a
poll I'm i'm certain that if you looked up
best movie villains Darth Vader is going to be in
the number one if not in the top three position
and and I think that they'll always be a source
of fascination I think I think that of late though
it's gotten to the point now where there's a
deconstruction of villains okay it's like well
what led to this person becoming the villain
right with movies like cruella or even the Star
Wars prequels right like what led to this person
they started out as good but then they became bad
well what is that journey like and that's
become a whole other genre unto itself right
the deconstruction of a movie villain and showing
it from their point of view and I guess from darth
vader's point of view you know he wanted to
set the galaxy right and you know so from darth
vader's point of view from anakin skywalker's
point of view he was doing the right thing
i don't know I and I think that you
know from thanos's point of view
the same thing from other great
movie villains point of views
you know they had a mission they were
trying to fulfill I just think that
villains always tend to be the most interesting
characters are villains always the most unlikable
or is unlikeability and villain two separate
characters yeah I I don't know I unlikeability
is I don't know it's like an unlikable in in the
sense of you know you're gonna like the villain
otherwise the hero has no journey right and and
yeah I think unlikable is you know maybe a term
better used for like a side character or whatnot
or an unlikable character might be better
way to describe han solo in the first Star
Wars movie where he was kind of he was selfish
he was out for himself he only cared about money
didn't care about the cause that the that princess
leia was on and he was you know parts of him were
unlikable he was still it's look it's harrison
ford he's very attractive man that chiseled jaw
sure I'm very envious of that trigger be mean to
but he's you know he's unlikable and has
a redemption right so that redemption
arc is important not just you know and
we've seen it happen more with villains
I don't think necessarily Thanos had a
redemption arc you know but the story
of Darth Vader is a redemption arc which is a
very christian story what about female villains
yeah because if you I'm sorry to interrupt
but walter white's wife in breaking bad was
she really a villain or she just unlikeable
oh that's interesting yeah I mean I would I
would probably say unlikable but from her point
of view I feel like the audience can relate to
the you know the moral dilemma that she's faced
with which influences her decision making so I
don't know that I would consider her necessarily
a villain but but you know unlikable in the sense
that walter white is you know he's our guy he's
the it's right you understand stories about him
and but I but I feel some empathy for her from
the standpoint of well she's making the decisions
for what she thinks is best so while while
I would understand with some understand and
empathize with her decision making wouldn't
necessarily agree with it was there a villain
in Amelie I mean look I think I think I think
the villain in Amelie was amelie's agoraphobia
really and her ability to relate to other people
that was the thing that she needed to overcome
here she is kind of in love with the world
but the shy quiet girl who you know has
you know she she gains this you know delight
over connecting people with with some aspect
of them that that reawakens some love right which
begins with that little box of toys and the the
and and her journey the sort of you know like
she's she's doing good in that sense but then
you know the person she's thinking about all these
other people and how she can kind of help them
along the way and she's she thinks about herself
last right but but then that journey becomes about
her you know overcoming her own agoraphobia I
don't know if that could be considered a villain
in the movie but it's certainly the challenge
that the protagonist must overcome and I would
say a mild case of agoraphobia in her case sure
it's not like panic no no no but yeah but you
know she she repelled from connecting with a with
someone who could be a lover for her she repelled
from it and she walked away fearful from it she
resisted it and and then it comes full force
that's such a great movie Amelie is such a
such a movie that is in a category all its own
that defies you know you know it's such a simple
story and yet a complex one all at once and it's
not a story that is told well very often so having
seen it in the theater when it first came out
in that movie is is just incredible who are some
of the smartest villains you can think of well I
don't know that I would classify them as smart I
actually like when there's a decent bond villain
but the fact that they keep getting tripped up by
bond means they're not very good villains you know
it's I mean it's almost it's almost laughable
or comical that so many movie villains
I feel like these movie villains
should watch movies with other villains
because then they'd see kind of
like the roots of their mistakes
which is one the main cause of death of a
movie villain is falling from a high place
so don't be anywhere high like if you're gonna
construct a throne room in a half constructed
death star try not to put it somewhere where
there's a chasm where you could fall to your death
I'm referencing of course the Return of the Jedi
and and the emperor and his untimely demise or did
he die I don't know was never really explained
in any case so yeah I I don't know I think the
smartest villains are always kind of several steps
ahead of their protagonist and I mean to me the
the trio of villains in the original raiders
of the lost ark I think are I think we're great
because at the end you know Indiana Jones did
not win he simply kept his eyes closed when they
when they opened the ark so he was immune to the
dark spirits that were released from the ark but
Bellock and his you know the his cohorts were all
taken out by their carelessness their you know
their their lust for power right of getting
the ark I feel I feel that what a lot of people
forget about you know raiders of the lost ark is
that you know indiana jones doesn't win he fails
he fails in the end the villains win and
then they become a victim of their of
you know their own hubris they're you know
they're taken out by the the deceased spirits
it was never really explained we had this
question come in on our YouTube channel from
KP is the name what can creatives do to help
make the film industry better and more free
for artistic creation how can we get
back to making great movies again
kp first of all that is a great question how can
we get back to making movies that are great and
by great you I'm going to guess that you mean
just a broad appeal and a satisfying experience
an experience where you walk out of the theater
and you know wow not only did you enjoy that
experience you wanna you wanna go back and see the
movie several times I have not had that feeling
very often I wanna go back and
see a movie again because I wanna
you know just ride that ride it feels it's
almost like a ride an exhilaration you know so
how do we get back to that I think what we have to
do is really foster and mentor talent young talent
not simply fill a writer's room and
there's seven different writers for
a project and really really mentor new and
up-and-coming talent and foster that one
number two and I know that Hollywood is is
averse to this but almost everything you see
that's on a large scale in terms of a big budget
is based on pre-existing material a comic book
that's been around a comic book property that's
been around for 80 years you know a stage play
that is you know been on broadway for decades
or a remake of a cartoon and now this is the
live action version and whatnot so seeking out
something original something original that that it
may have some source material but hasn't been made
five six seven eight times I know that's a risk
I know that's a risk but I think it's important
to seek it out you know San Diego Comic-Con used
to be which is something it's an event that I've
attended for longer than I care to remember but
that used to be a place that development
executives from Hollywood would go down
to san diego from los angeles and they would seek
out like a small comic book that no one's ever
heard of that has a an amazing hook an amazing
story it was a place to look for new material I
feel like that has to come back and in addition I
think it's a more informed development community
so that would be my my third thing is a
development community that really reads that isn't
just aware of you know like oh yeah yeah I know
star trek you know but you know has seen all the
episodes of every star trek series ever made right
in including the you know unaired pilot right like
just has has seen it all so I think a just more
informed base of people working in Hollywood that
that while they're burdened with the concerns
of like well how is this going to fit marketing
stockholders this just be aware of the you
know other creative possibilities that are
out there including original intellectual
property I even hate using that word ip on
intellectual property but you know there are very
few creatives in Hollywood now that are even given
the power to be able to exercise that Christopher
Nolan is is one of the people that's that's been
able to do that but there are far few so and then
I think part of it is also developing talent so
attending your major film festivals and looking
for movies made by small up-and-coming filmmakers
I mean I've seen it I've seen it in the
room where I've seen like you know a movie
made for ten thousand dollars shot with just
like you know almost not you know just like
these are the resources we had but you see the
creativity through the adversity you know there's
not a lot of money there's not but
you see like oh there's a vision there
there's a vision there's a visionary
that's behind that so I think it's
really seeking that out you know it's it's not
much different than you know someone going out and
seeking talent for a football team you know or a
professional you know a professional sports team
right you got to seek out talent and that means
you've got to look at people as they're coming up
through the ranks which is going to be your film
festivals and everyone who's been in a position
that is now successful whether it's a James
Gunn or whether it's a Christopher Nolan
whether it's a Taika Waititi all of them started
in indie film they all started with small movies
Taika Waititi had a movie that was at Sundance
Christopher Nolan had a movie at both Slamdance
and then the following year Sundance with Momento
his first movie following was at Slamdance
James Gunn started with exploitation movies he
worked for Lloyd Kaufman at Troma pictures so
these creatives you know really were able to cut
their teeth when kind of it didn't matter you know
the stakes were low you know the budgets were low
the stakes were low they could make mistakes it's
fine it's okay and then we're able to kind of
like okay get bigger and bigger bigger budgets
and prove themselves certainly you know all
of those filmmakers Taika Waititi James Gunn
Christopher Nolan all of them you know started
with smaller projects and built along the way
and were able to make mistakes at a time when it
necessarily didn't matter but also they had that
they were able to develop that creative vision
you know especially in particular if you look at
the movie that James Gunn made before he was hired
by Marvel to do guardians of the galaxy he did a
movie called super starring Rainn Wilson and it's
a superhero movie about a guy who's kind of fed up
with the world and just decides he's going to be
a you know superhero and he's going to fight crime
it's also a comedy I mean it's very much it's no
different tone wise with a lot of James Gunn's
later work but you see it the seeds of it in
super really where his kind of all came together
and and from that he was able to then do a big
budget Marvel superhero movie where he was given
pretty much creative reign he put together and
james has talked about this in other interviews
you can look it up he put together like what they
call a presentation some would call it a look book
it's this is what he wanted the world to be so
he he really laid out like this is the tone of
guardians the galaxy this is the universe it's
the cosmic Marvel universe which is different
than other types of Marvel movies it was you know
the first to kind of delve in that arena and you
know when you track the careers of those creatives
who did much smaller work and move up the scale I
think that needs to be developed more even if it's
a matter of you find a filmmaker at a you know
from a film festival or a filmmaker that put out
a movie on a small label like a gravitas ventures
or wild eye releasing or october coast these are
the small indie you know indie film distributors
that or there's a company called indie rights
these small look at these movies and you can see
you know there are filmmakers there are gems
there are diamonds in the rough that have put
out films at all of those companies that are
ready to maybe go to maybe not necessarily
a hundred million dollars but the next
level up and then see what's possible
and I feel like that type of talent needs to be
needs needs to be fostered mentored grown you
know would memento be successful if it came out
today if we'd never heard of Christopher Nolan
I actually think I actually think if
memento came out today it would be
successful it's such an original story it's so
it's it's you know one of those things where
it work it's a movie memento is on a short list
of movies that I see require a second viewing to
completely grasp all of it then you notice it it's
like oh it's story's converging right like it's
it's it's such a fascinating you know you
know twist on a traditional narrative right
with familiar aspects things we you know we've
seen before it's like okay it's kind of a noir
a mystery right but there's more to it so yeah I
actually think that that would be successful but
I don't want to talk about this too much because
some stereo executive is watching this right now
saying we need to remake Momento someone is doing
right now there's a studio executive I see you
I see you studio executive whoever you are
remake Momento yeah sure why not all right fine
go ahead but give the opportunity to a young up
up-and-coming filmmaker if you're going to do that
instead of post-its he'll use notes who knows yeah
so notes on the phone right you could you could
update it but in a way that's a way that's clever
and interesting not that compromises the story
I re yeah yeah yeah that's a whole other thing
how can indie filmmakers compete with Hollywood
the way that indie filmmakers can compete
with Hollywood is on the level of ideas
because there are ideas that Hollywood is
gutless to explore you will never be able to
compete with Hollywood necessarily on a budget
standpoint marketing money having said that
there are so many more things at your disposal
as an indie filmmaker that you didn't realize
whether it comes to talent and asking
someone who would bring money to a project
who knows who that actor might be who is like you
know you know maybe sitting around works three
months of the year and the rest of the time is
playing dungeons and dragons not a joke there's a
whole group of Hollywood actors that play dungeons
and dragons might not be a bad thing to learn but
there are more things at your disposal than than
you would realize so I would say focus on casting
focus on making the film because there's really no
excuse for an indie filmmaker because equipment is
so inexpensive I mean you know I almost look
good with the cameras being used right now
but and these cameras are not particularly
expensive to rent and or purchase so on that level
make sure that you have that covered but the way
indie film competes with Hollywood is with ideas
and then what happens is those ideas
will be ripped off by Hollywood
because that's how that cycle works now that's
fine if they hire the person to do that I mean
Sam Raimi arguably if you look at the Evil
Dead series the original Evil Dead film
Evil Dead 2 dead by dawn and the Evil Dead 3 that
that he's basically remaking the same movie over
and over again with a big budget I don't have a
problem with that because it's Sam Raimi doing it
let him do it that's great and and those
movies hold up they're really fun the Evil
Dead films with Bruce Campbell which have amazing
commentary tracks if you can track them down
very useful films from from sam raimi's early
career but where I think indie film competes
is ideas so here's what you do don't do what
Hollywood is doing because you can't do that
on a budget scale what you can do is explore
ideas that Hollywood would not have the guts to do
that Hollywood is constrained by checklists that
they must always have in a big Hollywood movie
indie filmmakers are not
burdened by that checklist
and you have to be fearless when it comes
to how you may be perceived on social media
right fearless stop caring what other people
think move full force with your creative vision
and that's not something that if you look
work for a major studio and you make a movie
with budget and concerns that I
think comes with burden I mean I've
you've heard the stories time and again
of of the the burdens that come with
or the the creative shackles that come
with making a movie for a major studio you
have complete creative freedom and you need
to exercise if you're not exercising it
why are you making it indie just just pitch it
to Hollywood and let them give you the money and
move on but if you're going to make a small indie
movie you better be willing to explore some ideas
because it's underestimated and under
used the audience's imagination I'll
give you an example a throwaway line from
Star Wars I know Star Wars comes up okay
Wilhuff Tarkin walks in the room Darth Vader
walks the room they they're having a council
meeting right on the death star and he
talks about the emperor has wiped away
the imperial senate they'll not be a concern for
us I'm not quoting it correct directly but that's
the basic line well one I'm an audience member
one who are all these evil men in this room right
this is already scary secondly wait there's an
emperor of the galaxy and there's an imperial
senate who is this emperor of the galaxy there
was an imperial senate why were they wiped away
and the the thing is is that Hollywood has become
so used to the fact that they can just do anything
why don't we just show that right so we can show
this well ultimately when we finally saw the
imperial centered in the prequels it was a little
maybe underwhelming like oh okay that's what it
looks like it looks like a lamps plus or you
know that's weird configuration of it looks like
a giant chandelier upside down okay weird in any
case but what I'm saying is is that my imagination
as a kid was utilized because characters in the
movie talked about off-screen events happening
and I think that that is a device that is
underused so as a filmmaker I would say to you
use the audience's imagination you don't
necessarily have to show everything
there are different ways for information to get
begotten across and not just through some news
report right that's the that's the lazy go-to is
a news report on the news you know they call it
the device they call it captain narrative where
it's like somebody that just sort of explains the
narrative to kind of catch the audience up with
what events are happening so my suggestion is try
to use parts of the audience's brain that they're
not used to using which is their imagination
I think that not only will you'll engage the
audience more get them to you know whether they
physically do it or metaphorically kind of or
they just sort of lean into the story they're
just sort of leaning in and and gets them to think
about what the events they're seeing like oh like
this and also I think it shows respect for the
audience right it doesn't mean you're not going
to have your money shots in the film whether it be
something big budget or whatnot but you know you
can expand your world by allowing the audience to
use their imagination and convey information in a
shorthand whether it be dialogue something that's
seen very quickly I I see that less often in
major studio movies and i'd like to see
it used more often in independent films
you know explore an idea that's never been
discussed or explored or explored
in a way that is new and fresh
that's what I think is the power for an
independent filmmaker you you need to really
make sure that those ideas are
so compelling that if you just
tell someone the idea they'll lose their minds
it almost sounds like you're referring again to
the topic of puzzles right yeah because you know
maybe showing a crime that you you we don't see
the crime that was committed but we hear about it
from different people's points of view that's that
could be one aspect of making the audience guess
yeah absolutely it it gives the audience something
to do because I mean look what's the number
one thing you want to do in a movie you want
how do you want the audience to feel you want the
audience to feel that they care about what's going
to happen next what's going to happen next right
and you're leading them along and you're giving
them crumbs but not all of it right and give them
some work to do and I feel like they're the reason
that the original Star Wars films hold up the
original trilogy is because it gave the audience
something to do there's so much of what's seen
in the original Star Wars trilogy that's never
explained you know that that are such clever
throwaway ideas that are in the background
that just spur the imagination and that's
hardly done these days I mean if anything
audiences are spoon-fed and over-explained things
are over-explained to them because studios think
that audiences are stupid and that's not the case
audiences are much more savvy these days they're
way far ahead which is why so much content is
like meh it was okay I can't tell you how many
times I've walked out of a big Hollywood movie
and forgotten it by the time I walked in my car
like a big action movie where you're like well
none of that really mattered what were the stakes
I didn't it seems like I've seen it before I
feel like indie film has the freedom to go a few
layers deeper and explore new ideas and engage
the audience with it so please more of that.